it's Germany's favorite domesticated
animal the piggy bank there's even a
monument dedicated to it and thrift is
at the root of German prosperity as
Michel
Otto knows that's what my parents taught
me the only way to make a larger
purchase is to save up the money first
saving money is deeply rooted in the
German soul savings account doesn't earn
much these days but is one of the safest
investments so that's what people do
saving for a rainy day is a german
tradition germans have been known for
their thrifty ways for centuries
economic historian Benner Abbas Hauser
says that mentality has its roots in
Germany's tumultuous history going all
the way back to political fragmentation
that followed the 30 Years War was
allergic so schlager people had to be
prepared for misfortune for example in
the event of illness or the death of an
important family member or to support
their children's education and send them
somewhere to learn something even done
big fool in situations like that people
needed to have quick access to their
financial assets - super passbook
savings accounts arose 200 years ago as
a government-backed form of savings even
the poorest families were encouraged to
set something aside for a rainy day
especially because there was no public
safety net
passbook savings accounts were a safe
option to virtual German economic
culture was defined by economists and
the German Empire in opposition to the
British example so it was deliberately
directed away from the stock market and
speculations and toward cooperation and
sustainability time and again
devaluation aid away at these savings
whether due to the Great Depression
hyperinflation or currency reforms but
the German people's savings mentality
remained unbroken because of spa did you
don't mean ideology of savings got a
huge boost in the 1950s after the Second
World War
everything had to be bought all over
again
Elisabeth unform maybe not everything
but a lot of things cause Colvin and
purchasing or consumption on credit was
not very popular neat simple believable
to this day even youngsters are
encouraged to save up money belongs in a
savings account where it's safe even
when interest rates are low and savings
melt away still a nest egg is essential
you shouldn't spend what you don't have
we learn that along with our
multiplication tables and as long as you
follow that rule you'll stay in the
black company off these other two the
number after a later and when Germans do
break into their savings it can only be
for something truly important